And we are live.
Hello, everyone, and welcome
to Active in France. Lab.
This is the third part
in a four part series.
It is Model Stream, 3.0.
And today we are here with Ryan Smith
and Christopher White and Max Murphy.
And we're going to be having
a really interesting discussion.
So thanks, everyone, for joining.
Just to quickly introduce ourselves
before we go to points a process
and then into the material.
I'm Daniel Friedman.
I'm a postdoc in California.
I'm Ryan Smith.
I'm an investigator
at the Laureate Institute for Brain
Research in Tulsa, Oklahoma.
I am Christopher.
I'm a Ph.D.
student at the MRC Cognition Brain
Sciences Unit in Cambridge, England.
I am next Murphy.
I'm a postdoctoral fellow
at Carnegie Mellon.
Awesome.
Thanks, everyone, for joining
for our panelists and the authors
for Max for contributing your experience
and also for
everybody who's going to be live
and in replay asking us questions.
This is the third in a four part series
that is going to be highlighting
different perspectives and addressing
questions related to the active inference
tutorial paper of Smith at all from,
I guess you could say 20, 20,
but it's been versioned several times.
And that tutorial is called a step
by step tutorial
on active inference
and its applications to empirical data.
So if you have any questions
during the live stream, you're more than
welcome to type it in the live chat
and we'll try to get to it.
If you have questions after this
live stream, just leave a comment
and we're going to try to address it
as well.
To learn more
and to find out about participate
check out Active Conference Talk.
That's all.
So for today in our third session,
we're going to be picking up
with just a brief overview, even shorter
than the second parts overview.
And then we're going to be diving into
two main sections today.
Ryan is going to be leading a section
on the neural process theory
And then Christopher is going to be
leading a section on hierarchical models.
So two very interesting topics.
Let's just start with one warm up
introductory question
before we go to the neural process
theory.
And my question would be,
let's say somebody were sent
just this third part of this
four part series
What would you say
is the summary of the first two parts
that we can catch them up with right now
before we jump into these next
two parts?
So what happened in the first two parts
that let us to want
to talk about the neural process theory
and the hierarchical modeling today?
Okay.
Well, I can try to start to take a stab,
Chris.
Feel free to add anything.
But it's obviously a lot to summarize in
just a couple seconds here.
But in Session one, primarily,
we went over the kind of like broad,
broad strokes, sort of a description
of active inference,
the ideas of how you can do
approximate Bayesian inference
to solve problems with perception
and learning and decision making using
free energy minimization
and expected for energy minimization,
where exact Bayesian inference
just becomes
intractable
for most kind of Real-World problems.
When you're trying to
do something cognitive or perceptual.
And then we went over
how to build specific task models
and specifically we used an explorer
exploit
a simpler sort of explorer
exploit model similar to you, a kind
of behavioral task that you might use,
and then an empirical study.
And we just showed
how at the level of matrices and vectors
and things like that,
how you specify a generative model
in order to simulate behavior
on that kind of task.
And that's
more or less what we've covered so far.
So that kind of general mathematics
and motivation of active inference
and how to apply it to to model tasks.
But that was all, like I said,
at the kind of computational
and algorithmic level of description
whereas one of the really nice things
about active inference is that
you have not only the computational
and algorithmic level,
but you also have an attached
what's called a neural process theory,
which more or less corresponds
to a specific hypothesis
about ways that neurons,
neural populations can be connected up
in plausible ways to implement
the act of inference algorithms,
and specifically that variational
updating algorithms
that are used to solve
the sorts of tasks that you use to model
with that inference.
So that's kind of where we're picking up
as now that we've got that, now
that we can build models and understand
their background and motivation,
you know, how can we actually move this
in into neuroscience and make,
make a trial by trial predictions
about what neural responses
you are to see, which you could,
for example, feed in
to like an F MRI experiment to see
if you can actually find correlates
of those predicted trial
by trial responses.
And just kind of add to that,
I think the general way
that you would feed it into an
AI experiment
would just be the standard way
that people usually do this stuff.
So you just put it in
and out of just regress and
into a G lab. Yeah.
And as you'll see, we can also do
it's not just up from here.
You can also do with I mean, we the
the most direct predictions
that make sure about earpiece any e.g.
So and we're going to talk about what
the ERP is
and the biology of it a little bit
along the way and other frameworks
for how people have interpreted it.
But yes, as we've
kind of looked at a few different times,
there's the observables, which are the
behavior or the neuroimaging
whether it's a fMRI or EEG or
some other type of measurement technique.
And then there's
the measurement of behavior.
And we're talking about models
that start from those observables
and then do some interesting
generative modeling under the hood,
and that's where the power arises from.
So any other comments on that?
Max, before we jump into part
one with the neural process theory.
No, I'm just
like I said last time,
I'm excited to hear about timing
relating specifically,
you know, gradients on,
you know, variational free energy to you
know, dopamine expression
and just hearing about
like the links between those
and why that might be an elegant way
to kind of express things
in terms of the neural process theory
and what we know about the connectivity
of these regions
and things like that.
Sounds good then, Ryan, take it away.
Okay.
So let me just
share my screen here.
Okay.
So just
as a kind of very brief,
you know,
sort of just catch people up a bit
So we we started out,
you know, like describing
active inference, like I said, at the
level of generative models
and those.
So I'm trying to find the right
figure here.
And those have this
particular sort of graphical structure.
And just focusing on
the one on the bottom right here,
which is the full generative model,
you have a particular set of observations
over time, this 010203 thing.
And then you have particular
hidden states.
So beliefs about what's going on
out in the world outside of the brain.
And so you have your beliefs
about what happened at time one
and then time two, and then time three.
And this a matrix thing
is what encodes the likelihood mapping
or the belief about
what outcomes will be present
if particular states out in the world
are the case.
And then you have beliefs
about how in this B matrix thing here
about how if you're in particular
states of time, one how that's
going to transition into different states
of time two and so forth.
And the study thing
is just an initial prior
about what
state you're going to be at time one
and then
you have policies pi up here
which control
which allow the agent to control
some of the transitions between states.
So for instance, the transition
of moving my leg up versus down, right?
Would be something
that the agent could control
and then policies are selected
based on this thing,
which is the expected for energy,
which is a function of C,
which is your preferences so the outcomes
that you prefer over others.
So policies are selected
that are going to transition
between states
that generate outcomes or observations
that are as close
to preferences as possible.
And then policies are also
in part controlled by E,
which is a prior over policies
that acts
as a kind of influence of habits
and the schema thing,
which will be important
in the normal process
theory I'll talk about, which is
it's essentially
it's like a temperature parameter
more or less on like a dynamically
updated temperature parameter
that basically controls
how much the expected for energy
contributes to policy selection.
So it's basically saying
if I don't trust my model very much
then policy selection
is going to be influenced by, I expected
for energy to less and by habits more.
And the way the gamma is updated
through this hyper parameter beta,
which again, I'll,
I'll cover this on all more detail
last time, but I'm just kind of reminding
the reader about the elements
that are going to correspond
to different aspects of the
of the neural process theory.
So and just my only app
and my only comment on this is again,
think about incremental layers
of complexity in the model.
On the top left is static perception,
hidden states, observable states.
And you're doing inference
on the hidden states
as given your prior D so instantaneous
hidden state inference given observables
bottom left,
you're talking about hidden states
changing through time with the inference
of a B matrix top right.
You introduce the idea that PI policy
is going to intervene into how states
change through time and that that policy
is selected by a preference
C that gets transmuted
into a free energy.
And then the bottom right
is the full fleshed out skeleton
where we also see
the gamma and beta as described by right.
So just start top, left,
bottom left, top, right, bottom right.
And that's adding up one more thing
for each layer of the model.
And then now we're going to be working
with the bottom right model. Yep.
And and the last sort of important thing
is about the underlying way.
So each of these equations
on the and in each of these boxes,
the, the way that you infer
beliefs about states
based on observation is through
a set of equations that correspond
to approximate Bayesian inference
through minimizing free energy
and expected for energy
So the idea is more or less
how the system
how in the normal process theory
does this system settle
on a set of posterior beliefs or states
through free energy,
free energy minimization,
and how in the brain that's
going to correspond to the normal process
theory to minimizing the particular types
of prediction errors.
Now, but I want to be clear, though,
that these sorts of prediction
errors are not identical.
This is not the same process theory
as what's associated with predictive
coding and perception
or predictive coding
as a continuous states based model,
as opposed to the discrete states
based models we're talking about
that have categories right?
You can only be in state one, state
to state three, as opposed to the sorts
of continuous states basis associated
with things like brightness, for example,
So so this is
this has a similar kind of predictive
error minimization flavor
to predictive coding models,
but it's not the same thing.
So now to start
with kind of abstractly,
the, the, the way to see how prediction
errors come in really naturally is just
to remember that for the energy, right?
One, one decomposition
that we've talked about in
previous sessions is you can think of
free energy as to be being decomposed
into a complexity,
a term minus an accuracy term,
where accuracy just means
basically
how close your predicted outcomes are to
the observed outcomes.
And complexity corresponds
to basically how much you have to move
your beliefs from prior beliefs
to posterior beliefs.
So minimizing free energy
means coming to the beliefs that
change your beliefs
as little as possible
while also maximizing accuracy.
So so that's the kind of idea,
a very kind of intuitive way
to think of free energy
and so given that definition,
you can think of the great answer.
The way that free energy changes
with respect
to these approximate posterior beliefs
that we're trying to come to.
Right.
These can always be expressed as
a particular mixture of prediction errors
I think about this is pretty intuitive
because complexity, like I said, is
just the average difference
between posterior and for our beliefs.
So minimizing that difference
can be seen as a type of prediction error
and minimizing.
And then accuracy is similarly
just the difference between predicted
and observed outcomes.
So minimizing that difference can also
be seen as as a type of prediction error.
So active
inference can be implemented
then as this kind of prediction
error minimization
that just corresponds to a minimization
of these two differences
at a computational level of description
as opposed to an algorithmic
or neural level description
So the kind of standard
and fairly daunting
looking figures that you'll typically see
and act of inference paper is associated
with the neural process theory
look something like this.
So on the left you have a bunch of
initially pretty scary
equations
that correspond to the the actual kind
of dynamics that a neural system
is going to have to implement.
And then on the right
and there's kind of a little fun
kind of schematic ball neuron setups
where you have particular layers that
are supposed to kind of,
you know,
kind of heuristics perhaps
correspond to different,
different layers of neurons
and cortical columns.
And each of these layers of neurons
are sort of proposed, again,
very just kind of like schematically
to correspond to different variables
in the equations over here.
And the synaptic connections correspond
to a particular mathematical operations.
So and so here,
kind of the easy way to think about it
is that these red connections here
are excitatory or excitatory
just means addition in the equations.
Whereas these inhibitory
bluish purple connections
with the balls
at the end of the arrows are inhibitory,
which just means subtraction
in the equations,
whereas the green modulatory connections
and that just corresponds
to multiplication
and the update equations
on the other side of the panel.
So the idea is that you can use this
kind of using this kind of scheme,
you can just follow along,
you know, just follow the synapses
and the ball neurons that correspond
to the particular variables
and you can kind of
get a sense of how you can just
connect up neurons like this to solve
the equations that need to be solved
to implement active inference.
But just say one thing about this,
I think makes it
a little bit more intuitive.
So because all of the updates are done
in log space
additions and basically like adding on
putting probability distributions
together is just addition subtraction,
which is nice thinking about it
in terms of this game.
And then generally speaking,
the modulatory connections
will correspond
to some precision parameter
which will modulate the precision
of the distribution.
That makes sense.
So that's kind of
how you think about there.
I find that helpful
in thinking about the relationship
between something like this
and the actual
update equations themselves.
Mm hmm.
Yeah, absolutely. Yeah. Thanks for adding
that.
It's almost like the anatomy of the model
we're doing a schematic neuroanatomy
that's a simplified or abstracted
based upon the actual patterns
of neural connections.
And then we're looking at the anatomy
of this computational model
and thinking about how it could be
plausibly carried out on neural
systems, neural processes,
but also it stands alone.
And so this is just another way
that we can look at it.
Yeah.
So so another thing that I really want
to be clear about is that active
inference, per se, isn't committed
to this particular implementation.
There's there's quite a few different
ways that you could come up with
to connect a bunch of neurons together.
To solve these equations.
So there's there's not kind of a one
to one mapping between the way
that the equations look and the way
that neurons could solve those equations.
So this is an example, but ultimately
it's a separate
empirical question what way
the brain is
actually set up to solve these equations,
even if those equations are
what are being solved?
Yeah.
And even if so, then we can also,
let's say turns out variational message
passing like marginal message
passing is just a really bad metaphor.
Well, that's fine
because we've got
all sorts of other things like late
propagation, blah, blah, blah, blah,
and they can all
I think the main thing is that you're
minimizing
variational free energy
and expected for energy.
The rest is part of specific parts
of the process theory that we can
hopefully falsify
or at least more realistically
not find useful anymore.
Yeah.
And so let's just say
one more note on that.
You brought up
how there's the computational
and the algorithmic levels,
and we're in the process theory realm.
So for those who might not be familiar
with process theory
or Mars levels, of analysis,
the computational level
is like the function,
like you have to sort a list
from the biggest to the smallest.
You can't falsify that idea.
It's computational, it's functional.
Then you go
one layer down into the algorithm.
So you say, I have a sorting algorithm.
There's many sorting algorithms,
but this is the implementation
as it's actually going to be written
in a certain pseudo code.
So that's one of many possible algorithms
that do a certain computational task
like sorting.
And then the process theory is like
the specific program you can think of.
It's the actual implementation now as to
whether it's actually
being implemented that way,
you might be right or wrong.
So that's what
we're talking about with the false
of a falsification of the process theory.
But at the computational level, it's
what Christopher just said.
It's the imperative imperatives
that there's a free energy
minimization happening
and now we want to be building up
specific plausible examples
to work within that framework for.
Just to jump in real
quick, it sounds like in the next stream
we might be discussing
more of these empirical examples
and instantiation, but just to say that
from the biological standpoint of what's
going on, for example, when we talk about
a moderate modulatory layer
or that that could happen
in a multitude of different ways
in terms of changing
what the membrane essential of the cell
is and making it more responsive
or receptive to being activated.
Or it could happen through,
you know, gradual plastic processes
that recruit more receptors to the
to the surface
and cause it to become more responsive
to any individual message.
So it's really going to be context
specific and depend on the experiment
and what circuit
we are specifically studying.
Yeah, absolutely.
And I mean, the thing you mentioned about
plasticity makes an important point
that I should make sure
I might have forgot to mention.
But but so in the context of inference,
right over the shortest time
scales,
we're just getting observations, right?
And based on the way that the current
weights of all these connections,
the system is just going to settle on
a, on a free energy minimum,
like a prediction at a minimum.
And then the, the activation patterns
in these neurons
specifically these ones at the top here,
the S party and S or by Tao
and Tao are going to be
the posterior beliefs
about what state you're in.
And but that's again,
just given a fixed set
of synaptic connections that corresponds
to your generative model now.
But with
learning like we discussed last time,
I want to show up learning simulations.
Learning corresponds to slowly
changing the synaptic the strength of
each of these synaptic connections
themselves.
So you also over slower time scales
minimize expected
for energy and variational free energy
through through
changing these connections strengths
over slower timescales via
kind of synaptic plasticity processes
like Long-Term Potentiation
and long term depression, for example,
as a way of improving the accuracy
of your generative model.
So so just to kind of reiterate,
inference corresponds
to changing activity levels,
whereas learning corresponds
to changing synaptic strengths
so if that's if that's a helpful
so so again, yeah,
I mean, like, like they were saying,
you have basically three
different levels of hypothesis to test.
One is at the computational
level, does the brain
minimize free energy
and expect to free energy or at least
is it helpful to describe it
as doing that?
And then second question is,
given that that first one is true,
which of several different
algorithms is the brain using?
And then question three is given that
it's using, again, a specific algorithm,
how are the how is the brain set
up to implement that algorithm?
So there's kind of a one too many mapping
between each level.
And a final point to make is actually
some people talk about these different,
you know, about quote unquote memory
and levels of
computational level, algorithmic
level and implementation level.
People talk about them
as though they're entirely independent
but they're actually not
necessarily independent.
And sometimes the algorithm
can depend a bit that can be dependencies
between the algorithm and able mutation,
because some of the things
that the algorithm is going to have to
compute are things about, for instance,
like energy costs,
which are going to depend
on the implementation.
So anyway, just
it's kind of a side point.
But but
in general, just to kind of you know,
walking through, you know, a sense here,
so you might start out with
these observations at the bottom, right?
And these are going to go up
through these excitatory connections
to this pink layer three here,
which is going to correspond to the state
prediction error we'll talk about.
And so these excitatory connections
are going to drive increases
in activity in these pink guys.
And those are going to be inhibited
by prior beliefs
about states at this higher level,
which jointly.
Right.
Is going to lead this to this level to
decrease
while the system finds states up here
at the level above that best account
for or predict those observations.
So these red arrows going up here
and can correspond to interactions
between A and oh in these equations.
And so you can kind of you can walk
your way through kind of step by step.
And we do this kind of step
by step in the paper
where each of these interactions
corresponds to elements in the equations.
So for instance, like to get states
to get states up here, right?
That corresponds
to this fourth equation down.
And that's by multiplying policies
by states given policies.
Right.
So I here multiplying the
the S's and the Ts here that are added
so will lead to the posterior over states
just as one example.
And and then another thing
that's important to
to stress is a lot of times
you'll you'll notice in these diagrams
that there are kind of multiple rows
kind of going back, right?
So there's like these three pink ones
and then these three other pink
ones behind them.
And that's because
each of these posterior beliefs over
states, the systems
trying to come to are with respect
to a particular policy.
So the thing is actually calculating
what its beliefs would be under each
of many policies where each of these rows
corresponds to a policy.
And that's what allows it to then
infer a distribution of our policies
based on the states
that are expected under each policy
and the outcomes
that they would are expected to generate.
So so again,
I'm not going to kind of do this for you
now just because it would take forever.
But if you just kind of
look at each of these equations,
you know, where addition
is, where multiplication is, etc.,
then you'll find that these connections
you know, basically reiterate or show how
how this can implement,
how the neural connections can implement
each of these equation equations.
But to to kind of go into certain
aspects of how this would work
and where the neural processing
really comes in in terms of making
empirical predictions just, just.
Just to jump in real quick
for the sake of moving forward,
just to help me thinking about what
the biology is as we start to talk
about the normal process theory
here you have PI
and you have kind of like,
you know, connections
that are inhibitory excitatory.
Sometimes when I think about phenomena
in the biology
you know, you have an emergent concept
that that's
the result of kind
of a population of cells in this case.
Would it be better to think of this
like a policy as the actual like,
you know, the activation
I'm looking at a single neuron
or am I going to be thinking about that
like at a, you know, a layer or
population level.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. And a very,
very good point.
I mean, I guess that is a very schematic.
And any act of inference,
maybe you'll see that,
you know, the statement as they chase
balls is supposed to correspond
to a population of neurons
Right.
So a population where I mean,
just as one example, right?
Like one subset of neurons
in a given population might encode
the expected free energy of each policy
Right.
So activation across the population of
neurons would have code, for instance,
a distribution over
and all the policies being considered
or something,
something along those lines.
So yeah, no, no, no one's
no one's thinking about this
as each of these being, you know,
single neurons that are solving all this.
I mean, that would be it really.
It'd be a really vulnerable system.
Very little damage to that system where
there would knock the whole thing out.
So, so, so yes, definitely there
there's what's
supposed to correspond to populations,
but a lot of the details of that is
really kind of under specified in the,
in the theory stated.
It's still fairly abstract
kind of at the level I'm showing here.
And so
so that that helpful.
Yeah. Yeah.
That does Okay.
So okay,
so the first one here to focus on
the left
are so this epsilon pi tau thing
and this is what's called state
prediction error.
And more or less what this does is
by minimizing this,
we end up with a posterior overstates
and then the actual variational
for energy for which policy
is just calculated based on beliefs
about states and that error signal.
So and this corresponds to layer three
and layer two here in the
in the schematic on the on the right.
So to to give you a sense so in the paper
we show a specific example,
like a work example of calculating
this kind of prediction error.
And so what this says,
so this is the prediction
error for each policy
and for each time point tile.
And the the
first part here this one half line
B Pi tile as I tell -1 etc.
all the way over the whole thing
here with the B's that are multiplied
by one half, you can think of this whole
entire thing as your prior expectation.
So be from Chi-Town -1.
This is saying,
what do I expect about my current state,
given the state
that I was just in before?
Whereas this one is something
a little more interesting.
It's saying
this is saying sort of beliefs about
expectations that come from the future.
So, you know, what are my beliefs
about a state at a given time?
Given my beliefs about the state
after that?
And, you know, this this might seem
a little bit counterintuitive, but
it allows for retrospective inference
which is something that humans
definitely do.
So think about.
Think about a case where you're sitting
in a room and it's dark
and you don't know whether the room
is the green room or the red room.
And but you sit there for like 5 minutes
and then all of a sudden
you turn on the light
and you see that the room is red.
You don't just infer I'm in a red room.
Now, you infer
I've been in a red room the whole time.
So your beliefs about
the past are updated
based on your beliefs
about the current time point.
So what this this second be here.
So expectations
propagating from the future to the past
allows you
to come to beliefs about the states
you were in an earlier times
based on beliefs about later times.
And and so so it's important
to also reiterate here
that each of these essays is for,
you know, as Pie Town -1
and these beliefs about each asset
each time
points are updated at every time point.
So at time three, I can observe something
and update my belief about
the state at time one.
So this is kind of being
re computed
at each time point with a new observation
but about each time point, you know, in
both the past in the future
as well as the present
so, so broadly, then this whole thing,
this one half times
both of these businesses
is your prior expectation.
And then that gets added
to the likelihood
function here, which is so a
times oh, which is the actual observation
at a given time.
And so this is like your this thing
together is like your likelihood
and so this again is very similar
to just kind of another form
of representing
Bayes theorem where you have priors
and you have a likelihood
and you're trying to come to something
that will inform your posterior beliefs
or states.
And then that whole thing is subtracted
from beliefs about the current state
at that moment.
And more or less, if you just kind of run
this over and over again,
you'll settle on a set of beliefs
about states
that minimizes this thing.
And just to show an example of that,
we specify here,
you know, what a could look like.
Right. So in this case,
state
one versus state to the two column state,
one would generate, say, observation
one with 0.8,
whereas state two here, right.
And the right column would generate
outcome one with 0.4 and so forth.
So that would be your likelihood.
Now be here.
Like I said before, this is your prior
from based on the previous time point.
And here we're just saying column again
here is state at time Tao
and a row is time to -1 or
you know, from time -1 This is basically
this is saying given that I was in a
given that I was in a state at time.
Tao What is my belief about the state
I'll transition to?
So this is saying,
I believe if I'm in state one, I'm
most likely staying at state one.
But there's a point two probability
that I could move to state to
whereas the B pital
is .3.3 and .7.7,
which means no matter what
I expect, it's more likely I'm
going to move to state two.
And then what I actually observe
is outcome one
and my prior beliefs are just 25.5.
So I have no, I didn't have
a strong prior either way to start with
and this V thing is
just a depolarization variable
which doesn't come into this prediction
error equation.
So I'll just
kind of leave that for below.
But so this is just an example of how
if you plug
in each of these
things into this equation,
then just kind of follow along
with the numbers.
Eventually
you'll end up with this prediction error,
this -0.2231 negative .999163
and and you can think about
and so then if we move
here, then we can take this V,
which is your initial kind
of depolarization
level in a given neuron
then you add the prediction
error to that.
So the depolarization,
the polarization level changes
so as to be a change in the activity
level of the neuron
in terms of depolarization.
But then posteriors overstates
then correspond to normalizing,
putting a soft max over
this depolarization which then turns it
into your actual posterior or states.
So this is based so this ultimately says
my posterior belief
is that I'm more likely in state
1.6, six, seven, six, seven.
Then in being in state, 2.3,
three, three.
And this then would correspond
to the firing rates
in the process theory associated with
each possible state.
So V is going to be your depolarization
and S is going to be
the resulting firing range.
Add something to this.
So generally speaking, easier or sorry.
Epsilon. Epsilon.
Yeah, a little epsilon is a free energy
gradient
It is a variational range gradient.
And then this awesome.
What we what we end up doing here when
we're adding essentially when we have V,
when we're placing our negative
fringe gradient, we're essentially
just doing a gradient descent
on variational free energy.
That's exactly what this is actually,
and that's how it's implemented
in the code only difference
between this
and what we're doing in the code
is that we have a little steps,
have a little step thing.
So we divide our epsilon by like two
or whatever
time constants for gradient descent is.
So. You know,
tying it back to that previous schematic
that we had where we had
the arrows that were excitatory
and we're adding this on to the putative,
you know, membrane potential
that we have described here
that might reflect
these kind of probabilities.
Then if we have this kind of perhaps this
if this were an excitatory interaction
that we were looking at,
then maybe if that excitatory interaction
from one particular layer to another
was representing that
variational free energy gradient, we
might expect to see this kind of response
and we might measure that in terms
of some kind of related, you know,
bio like biomarker
of interest.
Is that more or less just.
Yeah, I mean, so well,
I mean, just to go back to the kind of
schematic here, like where this is
happening is like right here, right?
So a B from time one, right?
Which is this purple guy.
So S through B from the previous time
point adds on to the prediction error
at the current time point
and s from the future
believe about the future also adds here.
Whereas the likelihood of a
Yeah.
Is added from from oh,
this is an arbitrary thing here
anyway.
I mean, so that's, that's the
I have to walk through a little bit
to figure out where this
inhibitory what it's inhibitory
when it's coming from
this is the minus L and Yeah.
The current state. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay.
But anyway,
so that's, that's kind of as an example
but, but yes, so,
so by doing that you get this posterior
over states that gives you both
predicted depolarization levels and cells
and predicted firing rates.
And that being said,
those and of themselves are not that easy
to to measure empirically
unless you're doing like a single cell
recording or something like that.
And so the idea that gets taken to
our front here is how you can get
from these predicted firing rates
to something that you can measure
like event
related potentials in doing EEG
or electroencephalography,
where you have a bunch of electrodes
basically attached to somebody's scalp
and you're measuring changes
in neural activity,
changes and potentials
through the scalp from the brain.
When a person is exposed
to a particular stimulus
and the
the normal process theory,
the kind of prediction is that
the Europeans are going to correspond
to the rate of change
in beliefs,
which is going to be the rate of change.
And there's a slight
the rate of change.
And in v very change,
this depolarization thing,
which is going to be a prediction error.
So so just to show an example of this
that me and Chris published recently
in the literature
on the on visual consciousness,
you know,
there's a big interest in in what areas
are specific
to having a conscious experience
and an example of an group
that in the past has been linked
to a conscious experience.
But more recently
and there's been some sort of controversy
because it looks like you're going
to get these three potentials
in a way that's not specific
to your conscious experience.
And so we're interested in seeing
whether the neural process theory
would allow us to kind of show
where this is coming from and could
reconcile these sorts of results.
And so it was based on this
really kind of
simple paradigm where you start out
the person who starts out
looking at a stimulus like this
where there's just these red discs
and these kind of slanty lines.
And then in some trials, what will happen
is they'll kind of transiently
be a little square here that comes up
in the midst of this slanting lines.
Then it'll go away
And basically, what, what
what the manipulation
is, is in some cases you have the person,
you know, focus specifically
on these red desks on the outside
to see if they change color.
And then you ask at the end, you know,
did you ever notice
the square things that pop up
And there are cases when
when they do see the square in cases
when they don't
and you're
looking for differences in the group
is corresponding to when they do versus
they don't under conditions
of different sorts of attention.
And so what?
So what we were trying to do
is to see whether
when you built
an active inference model
that that corresponded to this particular
tension, a task
that's called inattentional blindness
task, you know,
could we reproduce the the P3 pattern
so that's kind of in red here.
This extra
dip in
neural activity as measured by EEG,
that looks like it
typically only happens when a person
consciously experienced something.
But with these recent exceptions
where it looks like it depends
just on whether a stimulus is a task
relevant or not.
And Chris, actually I think, you know,
this was primarily your work.
So so maybe you could describe this
in a little more detail.
Yeah. Yeah.
So first of all, I think to
just give a shout out because we've got
the reference on the slides is this
paradigm was designed by Michael Pitts
and he has done
a lot of really incredible
empirical work on visual consciousness.
So just to kind of want to acknowledge
that anyway.
So generally speaking,
there's three phases in this experiment.
So phase one is they're not told there's
going to be a square
kind of self-assemble and they're asked
just to monitor the disks on the outside.
And then there's
a huge literature on this.
But generally speaking,
in a central blindness,
when you have a set up
that's kind of analogous to that, about
50% of people are intentionally blind
to whatever your manipulation is.
So I think they're really famous.
One is like a group.
If you ask people to monitor
how many times a
basketball is being passed back and forth
within a group of people,
a gorilla can walk past
and wave at people, and about 50% of them
don't report seeing it
So the idea here is just kind of
operationalize
that a little bit more carefully.
And then in phase two is after everyone's
kind of being because
like literally when you ask people off
to phase one, hey, did you see a square,
you're kind of alerting to them the fact
that there was a square present there.
But it's still not
the square start task relevant.
So in phase two, they just do exactly
the same task on the external disks.
And in phase three,
the manipulation is they
then say, Okay, well,
we now want you to count how many times
I'll hit a button whenever the square is
and so the idea was, was that if you kind
of see here when we say percent saying,
we basically said a hierarchical model,
which we're gonna look at in a minute.
And we just had it kind of report
what type of trial
it thought it was in,
did it see a line or not
where a line was just like a kind
of this categorical variable,
or did it see a square
and essentially we just in the same way
that you might in psycho physics,
like titrate the stimulus
or the contrast of a stimulus or whatever
until people say it.
50% of the time, basically what we did
was we titrated it until the model saw it
50% of the time,
or titrate the precision of the matrix
kind of corresponding
to contrast or whatever.
And then we just manipulate attention
where attention corresponds to basically
how precise the model's matrix was
And what we showed was that
when attention, which we operationalized,
is basically like when two steps
of attention with focal attention and
like super precise task, relevant
attention when those is the focal
attention condition, the model reported
saying the thing 99% of the time.
So basically all the time
and when there was precise task
relevant attention the model reported
seeing 100% the time again.
But we said dissociation
between the presence of the P3 in line
with empirical results and so the idea.
So I can actually just highlight
this since I've known that the cursor so
so in this first condition
so this is when like Chris said the
you know the thing had no expectation
right that it was going to that
there's going to be any square there.
And and the precision of the matrix
was low because there was no attention.
And so as a result, the start of the
simulated air appears flat.
And similarly this the second
the second step here,
which is what would correspond to a dip
here, is absent.
And here at the bottom
are the simulated firing rates.
So on the first level, basically
when black at the bottom changes
to black at the top,
that just means it starts to believe
the upper row is a belief
that the square was present.
And the bottom is the belief
that the square was absent.
So basically what this means is
when it goes from black
at the bottom to black at the top,
that the belief changes.
So it's more likely
that the stimulus was present.
And then you can see
because the matrix is imprecise
then, which corresponds
to like a low stimulus strength.
And this then this is not very
you know, it's still pretty blurry.
And then the second level,
these are beliefs about sequences
that are what's actually going on.
In other words, did it go from no square
to square and back to know square?
And you can see that
the beliefs remain really imprecise
because it's not it's
not attending to it.
It's not task relevant.
In this case, though, I was talking about
you can see that
even though it's not task relevant,
the beliefs at the higher level
ultimately do converge onto this top row,
which is the one
where the square was present.
But you can see that the beliefs change
pretty gradually,
whereas one attention was precise
because it was task relevant
then you can see that the belief changes
from being kind of flat over these past
and two possible top states
to being black, fully confident
that the square turned on and off.
And that really quick change in beliefs
is what corresponds to the strong ERP.
And in this case,
because of the higher level,
what's that kind of late
ERP corresponding to the P three?
So really what's going on
is the prediction of the neural process
theory is that it's going to be
the rate of change in beliefs.
Basically, that is what's going to be
measured as as an ERP
yeah.
When you think of the owner
say about that, Chris.
No, no, not at all.
I mean, one thing I just want to
highlight is like the only difference
between phase one and phase
two is a very slight difference.
In the precision of the matrix that we
took to basically be the addition
of some some slight focal attention
And but
you can see like just looking at
the figures, like it really made very a
very minor difference,
but it still bumped it up enough
and above the threshold
just enough for it
to basically go from 50% report
to basically 100% report.
Just also one point on the ERP
or the event related potential, it's
defined on the bottom left of the slide.
It's like a population level
measure of the electromagnetic activity
in populations of cells in the brain.
And so it's kind of like on the left,
if something's passing under the radar,
the population is not changing
in broad strokes.
But then when there's this event
that's task relevant, it transiently
synchronizes the population to be doing
certain things in a certain timing
and then that's reflected by changes
in the population level,
electromagnetism patterns
reflected by what are called ERP.
But there's a whole literature with
Princeton and many others on this topic
Yeah.
So is it just depolarization of dendritic
trees?
Yeah.
Which corresponds to the prediction or.
Yeah, which corresponds prediction. Cool.
So basically as prediction error
initially goes up
and then goes back down,
then that would be the
the predicted theory
So and this is kind of related to,
you know, pretty standard neural
mass models that are used in the
in the literature
that make pretty similar assumptions.
Right.
They assume that the average firing
rate of the population can be treated
as a as a sigmoid function.
So a function that looks like this
and of the average membrane potential.
And you can do things like, for instance,
shift this function to the left
or the right based on things
that control the firing rate threshold,
which could relate to inhibitory
interneurons or you know, there's a bunch
of different neural mechanisms involved
but basically this the point is
just that this idea
about where you get firing rates
from average member integer
potentials is not kind of out of nowhere.
It's something that's kind of used
as a standard assumption
in and
these sorts of models.
And one interesting
note is the soft max that sigma
that we use to kind of re
normalized probability.
It's actually utilized
in artificial neurons in neural networks
as also a probability
re normalizing trick.
So we're thinking about it
in kind of like the intersection of the
physical thing and the instrumentalist
approach, realism and instrumental ism.
And we're sealing our active
inference ship together through their
Mm hmm.
Yeah.
So so that's and you know, later
Chris will show specific simulations
based on an actual task that will produce
predicted groups that are consistent
with existing literature
when he goes to the code.
And the second part of this session
but so I'm going to sort of
stop talking about the stay prediction
areas at this point, which I again,
Chris, will pick up in his part.
The second thing that's commonly talked
about as part of the neural process
theory in an act of inference
is this idea of expected free
energy precision
being associated with dopamine.
And so as I write from the start,
that to be technically correct,
we call this expected for energy
precision.
In the literature,
it's often just called policy precision,
but that can be
slightly confusing just because
the precision of the actual posterior
distribution of our policies.
Right. This bolded pie here
corresponds
not just to the precision of expected
free energy
g here but also to F and to E.
So there are ways in which
the expected free energy precision,
this gamma thing that scales g
you know, could be precise or imprecise,
while the actual posterior
distribution of our policies
could still be precise or imprecise
in a way that differs
from the precision of G yeah.
We could be not sure what to do,
but have very clear
understanding of two policies
and their implications.
It's two separate levels of uncertainty.
Not quite that simple. Yeah, that's not.
Yeah, like so.
So a good a good example would be,
for instance, so in the, you know, in
the paper that I wrote with Caspar
and others on the I'm deeply felt
so deeply thought affect.
So the idea about changes
in emotional states or affective states
relates specifically to this better
term here that controls
that expected for energy precision
and now I expected for energy
precision goes down
and that will often correspond
to write a negative
or when expected for energy goes up
then that will correspond to a decrease
in expected for energy precision
but or a difference between F and G
but but there will be cases
where gamma will go down
meaning the model becomes less confident
in its beliefs about
its ability
to minimize expected for energy.
Essentially, it decreases its beliefs,
its confidence in its action model.
But there are cases when that can happen,
despite the fact that the actual
positive or additional distribution
over policies becomes really precise.
So so a kind of nice
example of this would be,
you know, say you're
kind of walking around in the woods
and at the moment you're really confident
in the walking around policy Right.
So there's a precise distribution over,
you know, I should be walking around,
but now you unexpectedly see a bear
now immediately
you're going to switch
to having a very precise post,
just your posterior distribution
over the run away policy.
And so you're going to have two policies,
two distributions of are policies
that are both very precise,
but they also but they change rapidly.
So the policy that the
that the model was confident in before
is very different than the policy
that the model was competent and after.
So despite that,
the posterior distribution
is still pressed over
policies are still precise.
The things very confident what to do,
gamma will still go down.
So the thing will feel negative
like emotion despite being very confident
and running away.
So the thing that the thing
that's driving that is f
I think that's
important to put in or to say
if you don't cash it out.
Right. Or Oh, well, I mean yes.
I mean just in the sense of
so f as F is going to be so based
on new observation, F is the
is the kind of evidence for H policy
at the time of the new observation.
So if F strongly contradicts G, then
that means that the distribution is going
to change in a way
that suggests that you ought
to have less confidence in G.
And and we can we can I'll show
a specific example of that below
and when we actually show
simulations of the
postulated domain responses.
But so the idea here is,
is that dopaminergic
physic dopamine responses
correspond to changes in this parameter
beta, which controls gamma which is the
expected for energy precision
and the
way that that these updates in beta.
So this equation here
just corresponds to the initial beta
so the non bolded one here
plus this thing.
So the posterior
distribution of our policies minus
the prior distribution of our policies.
So basically how much did beliefs
about policies change
and then dotted
with the negative expected for energy
that was that.
Yeah, that correspond to that trial
and then minus the previous
beta which allows us
to just continually iterate.
But because the change from post
to your beliefs or policies
from prior beliefs or policies
just adds F basically
the prior policies we don't show
it here is just Alan E minus gamma G.
So that F only comes in to turn the prior
or policies into a post area
over policies.
And so this change is driven by F.
And so the more the
F is consistent versus inconsistent
with G is what is what controls the
the agents sort of changes in confidence
about all about its G estimates.
And so it changes in that
or what are expected
or proposed to correspond
to a basic domain responses.
And then the kind of tonic
a level of theta is also proposed
to be associated
with tonic dopamine levels.
So if I could just very briefly
say something.
So essentially gamma is a
gamma is a
a right or beta sorry, is a right
parameter from the gamma distribution.
And essentially we get
you get this derivation.
So by the dot that that technically
that's a that's a temporal derivative
right.
And so this isn't exact
it's a little misleading kind of
because this actually
is a variational derivative of
gamma with
respect to variational free energy
because that makes sense.
So the idea is,
is that updates or changes in
essentially this by the value
or minimize variational free energy.
And if you want to say like that,
so the actual
actual derivations of that
get kind of kind of gnarly
but if you're interested, if anyone's
interested I would just say go and read.
And the appendix of an sales paper
that's in class
computational biology on the locusts
are really serious and
learning right in prediction error
where they should have actions as.
On as yeah.
And as in the appendix and on this paper
is actually really great for this
because plus C be basically like required
it looks like that
she still like every little detail about
deriving everything in act of inference.
So to as a really great paper
both in the main text and in the appendix
for show and kind of exactly
where you get each of these things.
Yeah, I
like it pretty much as clearly
as I've seen it.
Anything else
to add on the neural process front?
Because there are some questions and
then we'll head into the second section.
But this is awesome.
And there's a lot more actually.
Let's keep going then, then.
So yeah, we'll do more neural process
theory, however much,
and then we'll be taking questions.
We'll have an intermission with
a few questions that are really nice.
And then Christopher will launch
into the hierarchical model.
So, so to actually give examples here
because, you know,
everything we have said about that,
about dopamine and beta updates
is still pretty abstract.
So, you know, in the, in the tutorial
we give specific numerical
examples of this as well.
To show and give a kind of like geometric
actually intuition about this.
And so here you can see so.
So here we show that the prior policy
is this pi zero.
I guess that is just the soft
max of l n e minus gamma tree.
Then the posterior is the soft max of el,
any minus F minus gamma g.
So they showed before.
And so
and these are the equations for quote
unquote dopamine basic domain responses.
And so if you just take a specific
really simple example,
so let's say there's no hassle.
Let's say that Beta zero
and therefore gamma zero and the initial
theta posterior, those are all just one.
So we're just starting out,
you know, totally flat, basically.
And and
and we'll
say that the agent has no habits.
So there are two possible policies here,
I should say.
So the agent has no habits.
That's just one and 14 counts over
policies.
Now, let's say that G
is ten and nine.
So in other words, there's slightly
higher expected for energy
for the first policy
than the second policy.
So now let's say that
if the agent gets a new observation
and the free energy for each policy
corresponds to 21.
So as you can see, this is still
consistent with the ten and nine, right?
It's not like contradicting the policy.
One still has higher for energy
than policy two.
So when you calculate
pi zero using this equation
and these numbers up here,
you end up initially having a probability
over policies of 0.218 and .728.
So policy two is the one that
is has is
more likely
given the expected free energy
because it's lower rate
expected for energy as nine
Now the poster policies after we put an F
just ends up being 01.
And so if you take the difference here
so there's got pi death
so pi minus pi zero that ends up
being negative point to an 8.218.
And then if you do this
adopt pi dif with negative G
and these two betas just cancel out
because it's just one -1.
And so you own up with point you two.
And then if you compute the update,
then the with the change will be then
gamma ends up
equaling 1.28, which went up from one,
which means that you'd have
a positive phase.
A document predicted
positive physics domain response
and a way to kind of think about it
geometrically
as whether or not the vectors
corresponding to PI diff.
So the difference between fine zero point
in the same direction as negative g
because that implies
that they're consistent with one another.
That implies
that essentially the G was on track and.
That's worth a rerun.
So what is this geometric space?
And then what would it mean
if the vectors were totally correlated
and they were like pointing
in the same exact direction versus here
they're almost at 90 degrees?
Or what
would it mean for different arrows
to be pointing in different directions?
So these are the vectors corresponding to
the vectors here in G
and the vector that corresponds to pi
minus pi zero.
I mean, once again.
This is.
So this is
and I should say that these are scaled
and so that they're similar lengths
at the same directions
because otherwise one error
would be way longer than the other.
And the kind of point isn't clear.
Wouldn't be clear.
But so basically pi death
rate is negative point to an 8.2 on it.
So it's pointing left and up.
So negative X, positive Y,
whereas G is negative G would be -10, -9.
So it will be down and left.
And so the, the general kind of
intuition that's supposed to be given
is that
when these two vectors
point in the same direction where
that just means
that the angle is less than 90 degrees
then the gamma update will be positive.
Whereas if for instance
instead we do a different example
now the only thing we're going to do here
is we're going to change f
we're going to change F from 21, two
or another we're going to change g.
So G is going from ten to nine
to only being one and nine.
So in other words, while in this case
the first policy at higher
expected for energy Now the first policy
has lower expected for energy.
Now if you
run through the exact same set of steps
to solve the equations
you're going to end up
with a gamma of 0.14, which means there's
going to be a negative,
there should be a drop in dopamine.
In other words, the agent should become
less confident in its
G estimates.
And you can see that if you look at where
the vectors are pointing in this case,
then they're then the angle difference
is 128.6, six degrees,
so more than 90 degrees.
So therefore they point
in different directions.
So therefore they provide evidence
against G
F, if that makes sense.
Yep. Let me try with the dopamine.
So we're thinking of dopamine
as a tracker of confidence.
It has many roles and Colombo and others
have talked about pluralism in dopamine.
So we're not
there's not a lecture on dopamine.
We're thinking about dopamine
as like confidence
and we're headed in a direction.
We're on our road trip and the dopamine
coursing through our brain.
And we want to know how confident we are
that we're on the right path
as new observations are coming in.
Now, as we've seen from the earlier
sections, we're doing a lot of matrix
math.
And just like a vector
is a simpler version
of a matrix, and a tensor is a more
complicated version of a matrix.
They're all kind of in
the same math space and a given vector.
From computer science, it's
like two numbers that are in a column,
but also a vector
has this arrow interpretation.
So if someone says the coordinate three,
comma three,
it's like a vector from 00
pointing to 33.
So lists of numbers like a computer
science vector is basically
the same thing as a vector with a start
and a head entity at the end.
So physics and computer science
and we're thinking about vectors
and matrices, intensities,
and then we're laying out
after scaling and normalizing
which direction
these different vectors are pointing
and then it's kind of like,
are we headed on the basically
the same path is the,
the vector of the evidence sort
of pointing us in a similar direction
that we're already believing in.
Or is the new evidence
coming in like a tailwind or headwind
that's kind of surprising us
and it's not in line,
it's not headed in the same direction
as what we're already believing.
And then this meta with the gamma,
the hyper parameter is about
how much reliance we're putting in
to G versus our observations.
Yeah.
So I mean, another kind of a nice,
nice thing here
is that so as as Gamma goes down. Right.
So if you look
if you look at this poster,
you know, distribution of our policies
equation as is gamma value gets lower.
Right?
So as the agent becomes less confident
in its and its action model, more or less
less confident that its model will be
good at minimizing expected for energy.
Right.
As that goes down, then
G contributes less, which means that F, n
e contribute more so if an agent
has built up really strong habits,
then its beliefs
and its model will control action.
If Gamma is high, but if Gamma is
really low, then the agent will
just kind of choose whatever
its habitually chosen in the past.
So habits will kind of take over.
If it's not confident in its model
which
is kind of a nice way to think about
as some kind of analogs
to like model based versus model three
algorithms and reinforcement
learning for example, that again,
you could think about in terms
of actually making decisions based on,
you know, explicitly simulating
what's going to happen in the future.
If I make one choice versus
another versus just doing
what's typically worked in the past,
as is another kind of way to think about
what Gamma has arbitrating.
Did you want to say anything else, Chris?
No, I was just going to say there's
some really nice numerical results,
so I think it's gotten
so I'm sorry if I've forgotten the name.
I think it's Thomas Fitzgerald
is the lead author on this, but
they have some
stuff just showing that related schemes.
I think the equations have changed
a little bit since then,
but that pretty much the same
that this scheme gives very, very similar
answers as something like temple distance
learning,
which is a very simple model
for algorithm and reinforcement learning
and that's also I think, the gold
standard model of phase excitement
at the moment.
Robin, correct me on that, but.
No, I mean, yeah,
I mean it's like temple,
the temple, different account
of the reward prediction or stuff.
And yet we're treating basic
domain responses as reward prediction
errors and temporal difference.
Learning models
is definitely a very standard
kind of like widely supported view.
And this I mean the
it is that this this can this sort of
this sort
of active inference model of dopamine
is kind of saying something different.
It's not saying
it's a reward prediction error,
but it's something that will have
the same kind of dynamics
as reward prediction error
because if you think about it,
so say, you know, I'm walking along
and I'm not expecting a reward
and then all of a sudden
I get a cue that makes it
so now that I expect now I expect reward.
And so, you know, for instance,
like or say like I'm like a simple
kind of like experiment,
like a like operant condition experiment,
conditioning experiment,
like a rat or something.
You know, it learns
that every time it sees a light, it's
going to get a reward.
And 5 seconds.
And then the reward prediction,
our story would say,
oh, you're going
to get a reward prediction error
when the light rats is the light,
because now it's going to get
it knows it's going to get a reward
that it wasn't expecting.
And so in this case, though,
you'll get something at a similar
but for a different reason.
Where you can think about the rat
initially just kind of wandering
around, not being super confident,
you know, and in a particular policy.
But then it gets that cue
that it's going to get rewarded,
you know, if it goes up and pushes the
the lever. Right.
Is the standard way this works.
So so instead of it being
a reward prediction error, what would be
happening is the cue is actually
unexpectedly making the rat
a lot more confident in what to do.
Right.
But more confident in the policy
of going and pushing the lever.
So you're going to get something
that looks just like
a reward prediction error,
at least in that sort of setup,
but actually has to do with an update
and confidence about what to do
so so that's kind of in
part that's one
kind of intuitive way to think about,
you know, where similar looking dynamics
come from.
But but I should also kind of
be clear that,
I mean, this is definitely not
meant necessarily
to be kind of a universal
unifying account of dopamine.
You know, at least at least as far as
I can tell at
present, there's lots of other things
that dopamine does that,
you know, look like they couldn't
be explained by just this sort of model.
But this sort of model looks like
it's decent as a contender for thing
making sense of things
like why dopamine doesn't just respond
for prediction errors, but also
a response for events that are salient
for example,
this kind of saliency versus reward
prediction error sort of thing.
There's a couple others.
But but this is not necessarily
meant to be a
you know, this is all dopamine does.
But anyway,
so so just making that clear
So now the kind of last thing to show
and this is the actual
figure in the paper that just shows
both of these things, is that
if you do the actual variational updating
where just better continually changes
than the
the actual kind of gradient like the
the changes look like this sort of thing
would start out for instance, at
around at a certain value.
And then for for this case right
so it starts at
you know, down coming from one
and then it will
gradually go up and converge
after 16 iterations.
Is that what's that in the code to that
post your value or what Gamaa to be
whereas in this case
it will drop coming up from one down
and then converge over those iterations
onto this value of .14.
So it's not as though in the neural model
this is kind of happening
with one little step.
It's it's kind of a it's a
you know it's a convergence
that you can think of as related
to a kind of prediction error
and essentially kind of like an expected
free energy prediction here.
Some people have talked about it
that way in previous papers.
And for those following along
line in the code with this being the EMV
precision updating and.
Yeah, I think so. Yeah, there's a yeah.
To to play around with this exact
this exact example
as well as ones where you can specify
bigger policy spaces.
So like like when the agent has like five
policies to choose from instead of one,
which is a little more realistic,
it's just
it's hard to show vectors, it's hard
to illustrate those in like
five dimensions and so we want the two
for this simple examples.
But yes, and that if precision updating,
you can reproduce
these results and then try changing
provider better values
or changing genes to see to get more
of an intuitive sense of the dynamics
and so like in the
in the in the lecture might call it
when we were showing in the explore
exploit test model the last time
these sorts of simulated simulated
behaviors, right where the agent either
chooses to take the hint and then go left
or right to get a reward.
Oh, it just makes
or is just wrecks risk seeking
and just goes left versus right
automatically
instead of taking the hint first.
And in, in the previous session
we went over this
and but we kind of ignored
this bottom right section on expected
for energy precision
and these dogma plots.
But now that we have kind of
walked through that a little bit
you know, we can kind of come back
to that and see that in this case
the agent
started out in the beginning
and it chose to take the hand
and then it knew
whether to choose the left,
choose the left machine
or choose the right machine.
So you can see what happens
here. As well.
When it takes the hint, then it becomes
a lot more confident about what to do.
And so it's at that point that you
simulate a big jump in dopamine Right.
So in this case, it's not because it's
got a reward immediately. It's
because it got a cue where it learned
what to be able to do to get a reward.
So then excuse is left
and then it observes a win here
at the third time
player, the third column.
So so this is kind of an example.
And then in the learning simulations
that we showed last time as well.
And for the take.
Before we leave that side,
can I just jump in real quick
and add a quick clarification
about that figure
so in that middle panel four win lose
and you look at that matrix,
it actually looks like if that's the
expected probabilities for her win
loss at any
given time at Park one, two and three,
he actually it actually looks like
in this case, the way that the simulation
it's more confident
about winning on this time step
when it knows to take the hint.
And then after it's taken a hit,
it becomes less confident
about running is it is that.
It's actually to do with the fact
that those aren't so the probabilities
but they're not probabilities
in the way that the rest of the model's
probabilities
so these are these are preferences
where we model preferences
as a probability distribution.
I, I see.
So that has to do with more of the,
you know, it's had more update,
it's had more observations
at times three.
And so as you're going,
since you're it's an accumulator
in that optimization process, is that.
No it's just it's
just so when you're trying to encode
essentially
what's rewarding for the agent, right?
You're just setting you're just saying
that it has a particular distribution
over each possible
set of outcomes for each outcome modality
and that distribution just encodes
which observations
are more preferred than others
and formally that's just a fixed
probability of distribution over
the different observations you might get,
where the higher
the probability as quote unquote,
the more the agent
prefers that observation.
So that's the reason this is just saying,
like for the first outcome modality
is just all gray here because the agent
doesn't prefer a hint or not a hint.
And then the third
one here observed action.
It doesn't prefer innately to observe
itself, do one action or another.
But and this middle one observing
wins versus losses
versus
NOL just not observing an outcome yet
at the at the first time points
in the first column, it just does
it doesn't have any preferences
at the second time points.
So this middle column,
the thing has a strong preference
for when so this black one,
which corresponds to high probability
and has a strong preference
against losing
observing a loss
which is a very low probability.
And then the null stage
is this kind of like intermediate thing.
It's not like it's not bad like a loss,
but it's not good like a win.
That shows the
null there or the race
is because it shows a hint because
of the epistemic value of the hint,
I should say.
Yeah.
So it so basically what's happening is,
if you remember that the
this distribution
is a little lighter at time too,
because the value of winning is higher
at the second time
step than the third eye
because it can win $4
if it tries to get by, just choose
one right away.
But at the third time point,
this is a little less precise.
It's a little flatter, which is it
looks darker gray because the black here
only corresponds
to winning $2 instead of four
so the difference between
winning and losing isn't quite as stark.
Okay. Yeah.
So but the point is, it's
not actually getting a big bump
in dopamine when it wins, you know, it's
getting a big bump in dopamine
when it observes the hint because that's
when it becomes
confident in what to do to get the win.
And that's
to reemphasize that we're doing this
trajectory of policy, which is what ties
it to the path integral as well.
So each time point
that it's being evaluated, it's
in the past and in the future,
and it's conditioned on policy.
So it's almost like the reward.
If you always expect
the envelope has the paycheck,
if you get it
and then you open it, it's like neutral
with respect to what you already believed
about the way the world worked.
And you'd get a negative if it was less
than expected in a positive,
if more than expected.
And so in that way, the reward of what
is initially just pure stimuli
that could be rewarding or thought of in
that way gets moved up.
That's kind of like reinforcement
learning or reward learning.
And that's why we're in this area
of thinking about stimuli and policy
and rewards and risks.
Yeah, I mean, the idea
is just that in that context,
these dopamine responses,
the simulated dopamine responses
here corresponded
to changes in confidence
about what to do or changes in confidence
that your model will give you the right
answer about what to do.
And, and that will look
that will have the same dynamics
as a reward prediction error
from a cue that predicts reward.
So so the dynamics will look like
a reward prediction error,
even though in these models
it corresponds to something different.
So it's kind of like in behaviorism,
everybody can agree on the behavior.
We agree that if we train up the animal,
it learns to do this after X
experimental paradigm is carried out.
And now we're talking about internal
we're thinking either at a neural process
level, like which regions of the brain or
computationally like what is happening.
And then here there's a common trunk
with the predictive processing,
the reward prediction error, all of that
and the active inference models
we're talking about,
which is in reinforcement learning,
which is that over time,
the reward gets moved up to be associated
apparently more with the cue
than with the actual stimulus delivery.
But we're taking a point of divergence
in that we're adding in
a few different pieces that differentiate
in active inference, free energy
gradient, descent driven policy selection
from just
Q association, even though they do have
some similarities.
This is like a generalization
or a much more nuanced way
to approach similar situations.
Yeah.
And, you know, I ultimately write
the hope is to find situations
where active inference and reinforcement
learning models are going to be going
to make different predictions, right,
about what dopamine will do
and because that's
where you can actually say,
you know,
which model has more empirical support.
And yeah, Thomas Fitzgerald, I think, is
the paper that Chris was talking about
or you know, he did show
there are interesting findings
where when you get rid of dopamine,
when there's dopamine depletion
or there's some kind of lack of dopamine
in the system for one reason or another,
that doesn't
actually get rid of a reward.
Learning like an agent
can still learn about rewards despite
the dopaminergic function being impaired,
which makes it look as though,
you know, dopamine might not be serving
this reward prediction error
function, at least
if you think that reward prediction error
is necessary for reward learning
and and so there was he
showed some simulations again
with a slightly different formalism
than the current one, showing how
you can get the same dopamine responses
as you would expect in a reinforcement
learning model.
But it explains why
you don't need dopamine
to do the reward learning
but but like I mentioned, the formalism
isn't exactly the same as it is now.
There's a slightly older paper,
so, you know,
I think there's
just a lot more kind of empirical work
to do to try to kind of find,
you know, differential support for
one model of dopamine over another here.
Very any other any other comments, Chris.
And I think just looking at the time,
you want to kind of speed
as the slides and then get to the stuff.
Yeah. Okay.
So yeah, I mean, I can skip,
I can skip or to skim over a lot of this.
I mean, the last thing
I was going to talk about is that
this isn't used as much
because it's not actually implemented
in this way in the code.
But Karl has made this point
that you can also implement
and minimizing expected free energy
using a different kind of prediction
error called an outcome prediction error.
And that just corresponds
to the different elements
and expected for energy.
So which is here just
here is
just minimizing the expected difference
between the preferred outcomes C
and the outcomes that you expect
under a policy right.
So under some policy
for under some policy,
the state for that pie multiplied with A
will give you
the expected outcomes of a policy
so you're just trying to
this prediction error,
minimizing this prediction error
just corresponds to finding the policy
that minute or that minimizes the
the difference
between basically what you want
and what you expect
given what you choose to do.
And the second term is
the ambiguity
or information seeking term.
And it effectively you can think about it
as the expected difference between
beliefs about states before
and after a new observation.
So you're trying to find basically
and a different state
like the state that maximizes
how much information
you gain about what state you're in.
But formally, it's that it's the entropy
of the likelihood distribution
for a state
or how kind of flat or uninformative
the distribution is of expected outcomes,
given that you're in one state
versus another.
And in the paper we we go through
and numeric numerical examples of
computing these sorts
of outcome prediction errors as well.
But the basic point again
I won't go through them in detail is just
if you have some policy
that is going to generate the state,
state, one with probability
point nine and state to probability
point one, and your preference is
perfectly precise over observing
outcome one and that's your likelihood
mapping then policy whereas policy
to is going to as expected to
just generate .5.5 over states and then
and the outcomes that are associated
with those states look like this.
Then what you're going to get is a
policy.
One is going to end up
if you just do the math and out policy,
one is going to have a value of 2.4
for that for that term,
whereas policy two
is going to have a value of 7.3.
So this difference
is going to be a lot bigger
and therefore there's going to be more
outcome prediction error.
And so the the policy that
the first policy that's going to generate
the outcomes that are to
what you want is going to minimize
that prediction error more.
And so again, we just show examples.
We also show examples of, of this part.
But the basic idea here is
if this is your likelihood function,
then state one here is kind of imprecise
and what it predicts, right?
It predicts one outcome with point four
and another outcome with point six,
whereas state two
has a more precise distribution,
it generates outcome one with point two
and I'll come to a point eight.
So the agent would learn more
if it moves to state two
because the outcomes are more informative
and and so basically these work
examples just show how
the agent should to minimize
outcome prediction or the edge shouldn't
the agent should be driven
to choose to move to state to
And so
finally, and I'm not going
to go into this at all,
but we also show this
panel here that corresponds
to another kind of element
that's been proposed
in the normal process theory
that has to do with model reduction
and sleep.
And the basic idea is that sleep
allows you to search for other models
that you might
you might entertain
that can produce the same experiences
you had during the day, but can do
so in a simpler way.
So it's finding.
So sleep is basically still trying
to minimize free energy,
but not with respect to new observations,
but just with respect to your model
based on the experiences
that you already had earlier.
And that corresponds to
internal dynamics
that can essentially prune away
or reduce the weights
of synaptic connections
that are contributing less
to explaining what you did.
So essentially kind of noise
like like if there was a
bunch of kind of coincidental
connections between different things
you observed, then this kind of noise
in what you've learned.
And so you can during sleep,
you can reduce that.
And here's just a few papers
that have talked about that
and shown simulations
in case people are interested.
But so now moving on to
what Chris is going to talk about
are hierarchical models.
And the idea here is
you can just take the same exact
structure of the model here
that we've shown before.
But instead of
but put a layer kind of below that,
that's the same kind of thing.
But instead of the observation
those being actual outcomes,
the observations are just whatever
the states, the beliefs overstates
states are at the lower level
or the observations.
The observations for the second level
are just the posteriors overstates
at the first level.
And so that just looks like this
where you see here
that you still are selecting policies
at the higher level, although you can't
also select policies at the lower level.
But states at time to hear just
generate states of time
one and states of time one or states it
sorry states that wobble
one act as the observations for
level two.
And you can see necessarily
these operate over a lot slower
time scales
well so for instance a time one level two
the first state state of time
one is going to generate the
first state
at time, one at the lower level.
But then the lower level
is going to move to its beliefs
to state to over a faster time scale.
And so this whole thing
is going to repeat at the lower level.
So the thing is going to infer posteriors
over states based on two
observations at fast time scales
and then the posterior beliefs over
states at the lower level
are then going to propagate up
and act as the observations
for state
one at a time, one at the higher level.
And then that's going to transition
through a second level, be a matrix
to beliefs over states of time, to which
then is just going to provide priors
to a second trial,
the start of a second trial
at the lower level,
which again
operates over a faster time scale.
So essentially this whole lower level
model completes its belief update
before the higher level transitions
to its next state.
And in the normal process, theory,
it really just involves
taking the first level, just kind of
tacking on another wall of neurons on top
and making the observations
of the second level,
the things that drive
the prediction error and the states
as adjusts the posterior over states
at that the first level.
So it's
just kind of repeating the same thing
but at a higher level and treating the
the interactions
between the second and the first level,
the same way that observations
feed into the first level
and so.
I raise a question on this
slide from the chart.
Someone asked, can you please
explain the relationship or difference
between models based upon deep active
inference versus sophisticated inference?
And how is that
related to the current discussion around
dopamine signaling,
whether it's basic or non basic?
So two questions.
One is what is deep
active inference and how is that related
to sophisticated active inference?
And how are those related to what
we're discussing now about dopamine?
And I have a thought, if you can.
I can answer all these very quickly.
This is a perfect answer. Go for it.
So deep active inference
can kind of correspond to two things.
You can talk about it
in terms of using deep neural networks
to parameterized your your thumb,
essentially your eyes and these
and they matrices or your policies
that would be kind of like a machine
learning application.
And when I say deep active inference,
what I generally
and other people have talked about,
like the paper that first came out
cold, like deep, whatever,
the back of inference,
it was just
one of these hierarchical models
or deep in the sense that there's this
temporally deep or temporally thicker
and could say time, time
scales stacked on top.
And so then in terms of sophisticated
active inference,
that's just to do with policy selection
and where
you're essentially doing something
that looks more like a tree, such
so I would just say
it's equivalent to backward induction
and reinforcement learning.
So you essentially instead of saying
kind of
propagating forwards on a tree,
you start at your terminal node
and then you propagate backwards.
So you say, given where I want to go,
how do I best get there?
And then propagate backwards?
And then I don't really know
what the basic nonphysical thing means.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm not I'm not aware of anybody
sort of saying anything about
if there's any change in the dopamine
story and sophisticated act of inference.
And in that.
Investigative act of inference,
you're still you're still obviously
updating beliefs about policies
when you make a new observation.
But but yeah,
I mean, the main difference, like Chris
said, is just it's just how you come
to post your beliefs or policies by doing
the sort of more thorough research
where you have this additional element
where you say you know, given
that I observe a thing at time, too,
at a given branch in a tree,
what will my beliefs be at time, too?
And like
like like Chris said, it's equivalent
to backward induction
and it's, it's anyway.
Yeah. So I
without without again,
I don't think anyone's talked
about this much but presumably
you're still making observations
that update your beliefs or policies
as you move through time.
And so I don't necessarily see how
the dopamine story would need to change.
But but yeah, and I will say in addition
to what Chris said, there are really
two kind of related to meeting meanings
independent of the kind of machine
learning,
different network thing
that Chris talked about.
One is and like is of the standard,
one is talking
about deep temporal models. Yes.
And that's just exactly what I was
showing here, where the second level
necessarily operates at a slower
timescale than the first level,
because the first level has
to kind of complete all of its time steps
before it can provide an observation
to the higher level
and then the higher level.
So basically each higher level state
corresponds to a whole lower level trial,
you know, so if you wanted to,
you could make a lower level
trial, have ten time steps.
But the posterior of our beliefs
at that lower level at the end of those
whole times to all those time steps
would be, you know, what the observation
is that provides evidence
for the first state of the first
that the state of the first time point
at the second level.
So and then second
level states transition
and then the second level state.
So that basically one trial at the higher
level with a two time points,
each of those time points
corresponds to providing priors
for a whole trial at the lower level.
So you're going to have as many trials
at the lower level as you have time
steps in one trial at the higher level,
so so that's what deep temporal models
means,
just that the second level operates
at a slower time scale than the first
and provides priors for initial starts
on the first level.
And another
another meaning that some people use
like in the deeply felt affect
paper is just parametric models,
which basically just means
the first level out.
Things that happen at the first level
can be used as evidence for updating
hyper parameters for the higher level
and like in the deeply felt affect paper,
basically
we had second level states
that corresponded to valence,
but those were updated
not by first level beliefs,
but by changes in beta
at the lower level.
So when gamma updates were positive,
right, when the confidence and expected
free energy went up
there was a sending signal
other than updated
beliefs at the second level
that corresponded to feeling better.
Right? So positive valence
and those also
that state could also act as a primer on
what the beta update should be, right?
How confident the agent should be at
the lower level those trials go forward.
So it can also have to do with,
with, with
get its quote unquote deeper parameters
as opposed to just deeper,
deeper levels that control priors
overstates at the lower level.
But that's not as commonly used by far
the most common is just deep
temporal models.
Do you have any more to add on
the neural process or can we do our over.
And no neural process is pretty done
the only thing is, is that before
Chris starts,
because what we're simulating
when we're doing this
example
in the code of a hierarchical model,
the example we're using is an empirical
task called a local global
or oddball paradigm.
So Chris is just going to I'm
just putting up this slide
so that Chris can walk us through the the
design of this task.
So just before we cross over, just what
we take a breath, I want to make one
ultra rapid summary for just contrast
and then ask one question from the chat.
So the brief summary is we're dealing
with the active inference framework.
We are within free energy principle.
We're talking about active inference.
That's why it's active inference loop.
Now, we've heard about a couple
of adjectives, deep sophisticated
affective and even inactive inference,
and those have been in the titles
of papers
or they've been the titles of models.
We heard about just very concisely
about what deep can mean, whether deep
neural networks or deep time.
And then there's a third definition
of deep meaning,
like fully or radically parametric
and that is interpreted within
within the affective valence framework
within the paper
that Ryan just mentioned.
So that's deep and affective,
which are related
then sophisticated is related
to this tree search, counterfactual
policy and state estimation.
We talked about the sophisticated
inference in a previous stream
and an active is highlighting
more from an ecological
or even a philosophical perspective
about the embodied
and enacted aspects of cognition.
So that's just a summary
about a few of the flavors
under the umbrella of active inference.
And they don't necessitate
a renaming of the lab
because they're like variants
or paper titles.
But this is the total umbrella
that we're working under.
And then the general question
from the chart,
which I hope that set it up for,
and then we'll address this question.
Each person
give a very short response to that.
We launched into crisis
when preparing a model
for exploring free energy
principle active inference in MATLAB.
Do you often sketch out equations
with sample Bayesian calculations
for each term to help clarify
your thinking and track what will happen?
Or in other words,
how do you go from thinking or specifying
the generative model
of even a experiments into what you do
when you're talking like this
behavioral example to the code?
How do you do that?
I mean, so for me, honestly,
like when I'm actually setting up a model
for a task, I don't really think
about the equations hardly at all
because you don't need to write.
I mean, what you need to or you need to
focus on is just what the necessary
elements are in terms of states
and observations
and policies
that are just in a task, right?
So you have to think, okay, in a task,
what are the observations
that the participant has?
Right.
Is there just one possible observation
modality?
They either observed this or that,
or are there multiple observation
modalities like maybe they observe a cue
and then the observer reward?
Right.
And so then you need two observation
modalities, right?
You think about
how many in each modality, right?
Is it just cue or no?
Cue, you know, as a just reward
or no reward or is it no reward,
reward or loss?
So you just think, okay, what are the
different types of observations
and how many observations
within each type?
Just, you know,
what does the actual participant observe?
And then you
have to think about the states, right?
What are the
what is the participants beliefs?
What is the minimal set of beliefs?
They need to be able
to make a decision, right?
About how to get reward.
If it's a reward task, and, you know,
so that might be beliefs
about what trial type it is, right?
Or my beliefs about what
are the different choices I might make.
Right.
Like moving into the state of choosing,
say, option one versus option two,
you know,
and then you have to think, okay,
what are the different action sequences
right?
Like, does the agent
just push a button and get lucky,
you know, reward or no reward or,
you know, the the agent have to,
you know, make a couple choices in a row,
you know, just
what are the actual options?
Right.
And so, I mean, that's
that's really what it boils down to
is just figuring out what things that
the participant observe you know, what
beliefs do they need to make choices,
what choices are available.